now to go back to our as you can see we
have mr. M room here who is also in this
picture and who wrote the score for my
dizzy and he helped Kerouac who had
lived and narrated the movie when it was
finished in a sort of improvised ad just
poetry version so these are the words
that mr. M gave in an in an interview
with evergreen review basically in the
spring of 1959 the poom-poom ideas was
made Allen Ginsberg Gregory Costa Peter
loves give Larry rivers and myself the
third Avenue all-stars as one we
described us appeared in it Alfred
Leslie directed it and Weber Frank
filmed it
Jack had written the scenario and after
the film had been edited Jack saw it
because it was a silent movie Jack was
too narrated and I was to read the music
afterwards he alan and neal cassady also
wrote the lyrics for the title song pull
my Daisy for which I wrote the music and
which was sung in the film by Anita
Alice Jack put on earphones and asked me
to play so that it could improvise the
narration to music the way heads down at
our readings
he watched the film and made up the
narration on the spot he did it two
times through spontaneously and that was
it he refused to do it again he believed
in spontaneity and the narration turned
out to be the very best thing about the
film we recorded it at Jerry Newman's
studio there was an old friend of Jack's
from the early 40s and afterwards we had
a party jam session that lasted all
night Jack played the piano sang and
improvised for hours and now since we
have the man here I would like to ask so
how about that jam session that lasted
all night long well that was one of the
things that I guess we wish was recorded
that wasn't so the good part is that 50
years later this particular event is
being recorded and I just wanted to say
what a joy it is to be a Columbia
University I was here four or five days
ago when the Alumni Association
celebrated writings of Kerouac and Allen
spirt has distinguished people who wrote
books that could be judged on the basis
of their value not by the stereotypical
labels of beat or beatnik and this
particular time we're thinking of jazz
and his relationship to literature as to
viable art forms that can be judged on
the basis of their quality I mentioned
that because when I was chosen by
Leonard Bernstein as the first composer
in residence with the New York
Philharmonic and I was interviewed and I
mentioned the fact that my influences
were bought with his gorgeous polyphony
selling up 300 years of music from well
before 300 years or even DiMaggio
through Palestrina through Bach and
Brahms and Beethoven and Berlioz and
Bartok and George Gershwin and also
Fletcher Henderson Dizzy Gillespie
Charlie Parker Thelonious Monk King
Oliver Louie Armstrong and Duke
Ellington some of the people at the
Lincoln Center this was a 43 years ago
now I guess we're horrified and they
said well how can you equate barroom
entertainment with the treasures of
European culture and I said very
symphony very simply what they have in
common is purity of intent and an
exquisite choice of notes I thought that
would cool everything out it certainly
didn't what I surmised was they were
saying here's some schizophrenic with a
multiple personality disorder and a
career death wish who's going to ruin
our institution by mentioning the fact
that maybe this music might have some
great lasting value and I don't have any
bad feelings towards people who felt
that way because they were not fortunate
enough to have the blessings that I had
as a kid to have my uncle who was a
merchant seaman when I was seven eight
years old take me to the Philadelphia
Orchestra and then take me to the Earl
theater in Philadelphia to hear Duke
Ellington's Orchestra and explain to me
that these were
musics that the world was not flat as
calm as Columbus proved but was round
with a whole lot of different places
languages food people music cultures
ways of expression all of which were
precious many of which were much older
than this beautiful place called America
that we lived in and the fact that there
are even people here who've been here
50,000 years American Indian people as
we called them men who had a lot of
knowledge that we could be benefiting
from to learn about our own Heritage's
that we were born into and then being
grateful to be in a place where we were
welcome try to check out everybody else
that appreciate that so I was blessed to
have what vogner called
an open mind and an open heart when they
asked vogner what you had to do to
appreciate his music he said all you
need is open mind and an open heart
Stravinsky said music expresses itself
so really it's not that mysterious but
specifically to answer the question
since there's supposed to be a
discussion and not in the same monologue
the music for that jam session was a
small part of the film and if anyone
sees the film you'll notice some part
sound almost like neoclassic music
because I was also the composer for Joe
Papp Shakespeare in the park and I was
playing with Charles Mingus and Oscar
Pettiford Lionel Hampton and went to
throwing his monk's house all the time
which was my PhD education after
dropping out of Manhattan School of
Music I have six honorary doctorates but
I'm actually a history major and
couldn't get into Columbia so it's a
super treat to be here and know that
they have a jazz department which is
just like the classical music department
and it was Wynton Marsalis who made it
possible for the Lincoln Center to do
what all of us of our generation failed
to do which was try to put jazz just
where it belonged as great music case
dismissed now they have a Lincoln Center
Jazz Orchestra a Lincoln Center
afro-cuban Orchestra along with the New
York Philharmonic and the chamber group
and the theater and the Opera to be
judged on its own terms as great music
and that's something for which I'm
personally grateful and unfortunately a
lot of people in my generation is so
pathologic
jealous they can't say thank you so on
behalf of all of us senior poppers who
appreciate what went and did and I knew
him since he was in high school in News
New Orleans we all thank him for doing
what should have been done 50 or 60
years ago it's a beautiful thing and
also to have that here at Columbia is
really important not just for people who
want to study jazz but for
anthropologists lawyers doctors space
engineers anybody because jazz teaches
you spontaneity creating on the spot
dealing with the moment Charlie Parker
said now is the time which is the
philosophy that Jack Kerouac believed in
so much and we all did of celebrating
the moment to dealing with the event
what they say in the old testament
setting the crooked path straight when I
played with Mingus and the cash register
went off ding ding at the Cafe Bohemia
1955 I was a 24 year old hayseed
panicked he said don't pay that cash
register any mind he said if the cash
register goes bucket of poo you go get a
kiddie kiddie key and answer it make
that part of the music
so jazz teaches you how to think and as
professor Lewis said in the very
beginning with the relationship of
basketball to music to art to jazz and
to life jack was a great football player
and an athlete and we used to have jam
sessions at Ken carps house at 55 with
Clifford Brown bless his heart when he
was still with us and Monken and all
these musicians who would come and play
just for fun and let us young guys be
part of that very often the music would
we be playing for for 24 hours and then
we would go out and take a little health
walk to try to revivify ourselves and
basketball players some of the famous
basketball players at that time used to
come and I said that one of the
basketball players I was a gym teacher
when I was in college to help support
myself I said it's wonderful that you
guys appreciate this music he said no he
said you've got to come us come and see
us playing ball he said that's our jazz
he said at that moment that you make
that shot
move that's dictated by the emergency of
the situation and how you respond to
that situation at that very moment
one-time only event he said that's what
jazz is about and that's what the
highest levels of our game of basketball
we're about so there is a relationship
and one of the thing that I think it
might be good to mention for them for
all of you who are students that in the
40s and 50s when this music these
extraordinary kinds of sophisticated
music were being created and performed
people thought that Dizzy Gillespie
Thelonious Monk Miles Davis Charlie
Parker and all that hundreds of other
important musicians were playing wrong
they were playing out of tune and they
were messed up they thought that Marlon
Brando couldn't act all he could do was
scratch himself because they've seen
streetcar named desire and his role when
he said Stella defined that only his
whole career it also supposedly defined
the act of studio and Stanislavski
himself I happened to see Marlon Brando
when played march back so the kid the
high school put me in the 40s when he
played the sensitive poet Marlon Brando
could do Shakespeare and just about
anything he was also defined as being
wrong they said that Jackson Pollock was
just and Joan Mitchell and Franz Kline
couldn't paint they were just hurling
paint you know cans against the wall the
reality is that Jackson Pollack had
studied with Benton was an authority on
American Indian sand painting all of
them had tremendous schooling and when I
spent in the whole night with dizzy in
1951 he mentioned about pan-african
music for the whole night now I didn't
even know what pan-african music was and
he told me the whole diaspora of African
peoples around the world and how all the
musics that they created was left in
those places where they were and musics
that they took with them in their
travels they brought to other places and
how this arrived finally on this
continent in Latin America and a
different group from Africa that came I
had a different kind of music that
dictates what we have is Latin and
afro-cuban music and a different style
drumming
came to the United States and these are
all things that 1951 none of us knew
about there was no Columbia School of
Jazz at that time Jack Kerouac had the
same lines of information by hanging out
with musicians by being with people who
were interested not in what we were told
we were it was supposed to be but rather
more of what it really was about from
those who had lived it and who had
learned about it from other people
hands and mouth to mountain height to
heart so in the film that you saw the
saxophone soloist was a man named Sahib
Shahab and on all the talks that I even
pulled my days even my two three books
that I've written
I always mentioned he was the saxophone
player I couldn't get his name on the
credits because unfortunately they
didn't think that was that important and
I couldn't fight for that in 1959 Sahib
Sahab played with monk played with Dizzy
was a great master player I'm Larry
rivers who's a wonderful guy a great
painter and was playing the saxophone
and played for fun actually saw the film
I said boy how'd you like that Larry he
said man I never sounded that good that
was a Hebe Shahab and we also had some
wonderful classical players from the
European tradition playing in some of
the other music it was a combination of
almost Renaissance music and jazz and
the thing that they had in common was a
choice of notes where every note was
supposed to be a winner and if I could
show you one super brief thing that
little jam session was it just people
freaking out and hitting anything a
little boy playing the horn was Robert
Frank's son and we had that to show that
jazz was an open door so that you could
sit in as a young person now if you did
that in the jazz club if they didn't
throw you off the stage they would say I
think you better go home and practice
and you definitely wouldn't be invited
and you never barged in you came meekly
with your instrument and maybe at 3
o'clock in the morning you'd be allowed
to play one tune that was our school but
it was always about mentoring and trying
to encourage young people so in the end
the blues for those of you
that might not be familiar the the
rhythmical structures based really on
the two and four or what you hear if you
go to with any kind of sanctified Church
one two three it's basically that so if
you all want to do that
that must scarcely Pulitzer
prize-winning material